they don't look any different to
ordinary tomatoes which is very much the
point but these have been genetically
edited to produce high levels of vitamin
d
normal tomatoes like most fruit and veg
contain virtually none but just one of
these has as much vitamin d as two eggs
or a serving of tuna
they used a gene editing technique
called crispr cast 9 to tweak the
tomatoes dna we talk about genetic
tweezers so it really is very very small
nature equivalence it can happen
naturally or could happen naturally but
the amount of work and time
required to make that change and then to
select it and breed it in
is
prohibitively long
the technique is fundamentally different
to previous incarnations of genetic
modification or gm
most gm products contain genes from
another organism that confer a benefit
a type of gm cotton for example has a
gene from a bacterium to make it
resistant to insect pests
by contrast gene editing inserts
molecular machinery borrowed from
bacteria to delete swap or repeat genes
already in the plant's genetic code
before removing the foreign dna
afterwards
the difference is a crucial one because
this week the government will put
forward a bill making it much easier to
bring gene edited crops to market
and they're closer than you might think
this plot is the first crop of gene
edited wheat growing anywhere outdoors
in europe and the researchers behind it
hope that this change in the law will be
the first step to taking crops like this
out of field trials and seeing them
benefit society it's the first positive
step in crop biotechnology regulation
in europe or the uk for
a generation 25 years
and uh i've suffered all through that
period
we've been waiting for this for a long
time and i think
it's really a positive step
this wheat has been edited to make less
of the cancer-causing compound
acrylamide when it's fried
but researchers are also looking at
editing out common wheat allergens or
making the crop more drought or pest
resistant it's really important that we
don't miss out on the next biotech
revolution which is gene editing and
that is already off and running in some
parts of the world united states for
example several years canada brazil
argentina just this year we see china
and india moving on on biotech
on gene editing so
really important that we keep up but
opponents of gene editing dispute
claimed similarities to traditional
breeding and say the law change is a
step towards more elaborate genetic
engineering it's entirely misleading to
say that gene editing doesn't involve
the insertion of foreign genes
in fact gene editing is
a
suite of technologies that range from a
simple snip to the complex insertion of
foreign genes
and the traits that get scientists
really excited things like disease
resistance and drought resistance simply
cannot be achieved without these complex
technological interventions with gene
editing scientists have proven they've
got a tool that can revolutionize food
and farming but they have some way to go
to prove real benefits to society and
the environment
tom clark sky news norwich